transformation efforts in which they
said and I'll also stand out as an MP in
2015 I think what stage of pressing
about that is it sounds out a message
but it's not worth being an MP if you're
not a minister yeah and then the thing
about this is you know Giorgione's the
exception fist but most of these people
are standing down they not past time
h-hey Lansley Willits they're all in
their 50s and great Barker is just 40
eight yeah and yet they feel that
they're not a minister there's no point
in staying in the comments I think
that's a very impressive thing about the
status of pollen guitar most interesting
question to ask I think is to ask why
this change has happened here James as
described and for a very very long time
the disillusion with all our
institutions has been growing the
Commons is one of them expenses gave us
a really big kick and the status of MPs
is now unbelievably low you know almost
as low or you know in about the same
category who wants to stay if you've
been there for a while does if you kind
of think about if you're a Conservative
MP anyway the pay is great by the
standards of the average person the
average wage but not necessarily
compared to the people who these Emmys
have been to universe and we're
contemporaries it's much more difficult
to earn outside privacy is less that
loss of privacy also encompasses your
family and when you've been a minister
you know everything that you earn is
going to be gone through very carefully
the reporting in restrictions are bigger
than they were so people hang around
doing a Ken Clark they're gonna go like
Hague like well it's like Nancy like
Greg Barker like others because you know
being an MP now doesn't have the status
it did it has very little stages at all
most remarkable things is how cynical
the public
about our politics you know I mean less
than 3% of Brits say that they've ever
paid a bribe or expected to pay a bribe
for the use of a public service that is
lower than any other country in the EU
yet when you ask people in this country
I think corruption is a major problem
for Britain 69 percent so moving to
first the populations mean the
corruption is a major problem in Britain
today I mean I think running into that
headwind of cynicism every day it's just
debilitating personally I'd like to see
the house corners shrunk from what at
6:50 today to about 400 MPs I think one
of the problems is that MPs are doing
lots of things that should be done by
local councillors they are they are
essentially being social workers their
constituencies I think if you massively
shrunk the number of MPs and increase
the size of constituencies that couldn't
happen anymore yeah I also think we need
to take a look again about how we think
about outside interests yeah I
personally think that we should adopt a
more intelligent approach I mean so much
Tim you who has been de-sect by
association he was really pushing the
boundaries and the rules should be
tightened up so you can't be a select
committee chairman and have commercial
interests there in your field but I
think the Batmen Champy's we should be
more relaxed I would like to see a
greater acceptance at for example if the
point of David Willetts staying in the
House of Commons was him doing some
non-executive director ships and
declaring them in the appropriate
debates then I think we should both as a
press and both you and the electorate
should be far more relaxed about that
yeah so what is gonna conduct if the
public opinion is what's putting these
guys I don't know nice pink I think you
know James has put his his finger on it
but that finger ultimately points to a
choice which is RM he's gonna be citizen
legislators which means they get their
money from the unions or from capital or
from whoever wants to give them money
but
don't get it from the taxpayer that's
one model the other is they become
professional politicians pay both
taxpayer to do a job and they don't have
outside interests but if they do that if
it's a job
there can't be ministers as well you
split the executive and the edges
titular so that's the logic of the
choice
and as long as they they can't make that
choice they're going to be trapped in
the middle I think there's they alone I
don't know ever would have until
recently but I now do you think that a
full separation of powers taking the
executive as villages that sure you're
giving pawn this team role might be the
only answer because I think without that
we're going to end up in a in a vicious
circle where Parliament established
reestablish its own reputation and why
the needs of the executive and the needs
to have a message discipline
what will continues gonna [ __ ] upon
we might need to do something radical
because that might be the only way to
solve the problem